I didn't want to ask people for money
and I have a nonprofit life without
limbs and I was learning a lot about the
nonprofit I'm an entrepreneur I'm gonna
start six businesses with a quarter of a
million dollars cash I'm gonna get six
people to manage them all and we're
gonna make money and Waggoner
self-sustaining our own nonprofit that's
was the goal I did a big risk bro big
risk took it revenues were late expenses
we'll hire some revenues never came
some projects never were finished
someone took advantage of me of fifty
thousand G a 50/50 G at the time cash
flow crisis stopped for projects only
finished two and I lost all my money I
had panic attacks for 30 days straight I
couldn't eat I couldn't sleep I wasn't
myself
I was the what cuz I was so on that
treadmill but I was on a plane every
third day for four years straight I
wanted off the treadmill bank hit a
brick wall depressed cancelled contracts
couldn't speak very hard and then when I
finally told my my wife what happened I
said babe I lost all my money
she said straight up don't worry I'm not
going anywhere I'll get a nursing job
and support the both of us and that's
when I knew this is it
she is the one within three months nine
months later popped the question I had
had her feed me the cream puffs with the
ring inside and I said babe let me kiss
your hand I got me one one one right and
I went down on her ring finger and she
thinks that I'm getting kinky on her
I'll pull back and she sees the ring and
we got married six months later at Palos
Verdes and Osirian yeah and it's called
yeah four kids later in six years she's
she's the most incredibly inspiring
person ever